I know we saw ariana did cancel some
meet and greets how is she doing and how
are you kind of supporting her cuz she's
under a lot of pressure right now I
support her just by you know being the
best big brother on the planet sending
her all the love in the world and listen
touring is super stressful so like and
like it's really taxing on your body as
well so like I'm just like sending her
all the love and light in the world and
I'm gonna go be with her too and like
I'm on my way so Ariana your brother's
coming I'm super excited I can't wait to
go visit her too which city I'm going to
Dublin and Hamburg and Copenhagen
yes exactly I'm just gonna go get there
as soon as I possible give her the
biggest hug well and we saw like I mean
drama she's having to sue forever 21 and
a drag queen is saying that Ariana's
stole her look how does she handle
dealing with like feuds like that amidst
having to tour also there's always drama
you know what I'm saying and like it's
just whether or not you're gonna dial
into that particular element or whether
you're gonna like stay above it and like
rise above it and just like you know
reign supreme
and that's what I feel like she's doing
that's what I do in my daily life you
know what I'm saying like so you can
either dial into the drama or you can
dial away from it and just let it play
out you know you're not in control of
the results and like the sooner that you
get that anyone like the better you're
gonna live your life so just stay out of
the results guys I just have to ask you
you are such a positive person and
Justin Bieber also just kind of opened
up about like quitting drug use in his
past and having gone through that
yourself like being sober what was that
like for you to see him do that I'm so
proud of Justin my god I love Justin I
loved him so much like there are so many
videos of me like being like like
frosting we have it we had a hashtag
together he didn't know about it but I
did trust in for life so I'm so
unbelievably proud of him and anyone
that's going through addiction that
actually comes forward and asks for help
that's the hardest thing on the planet
and once you ask for help you're gonna
find that you're like there's so much
help available to you so like do that
ask for help ask someone in your life
for help and then you know there's a
bunch of hotlines and stuff that you can
also reach out to which is great
et spoke with Frankie Grande at the
premiere of the game changers a
documentary about former UFC fighter
James Wilkes is
quest to discover more about nutrition
how could the original professional
fighters be certain powerful eating only
plants I've been vegan now for three
months my boyfriend is a huge vegan so
he's been vegan for two years and I I
was playing bass about five years ago
and then it just kind of like like
wasn't it no longer like part of my
lifestyle like I wasn't figuring I
wasn't having energy or whatever but I
realized I wasn't eating correctly like
I wasn't getting all the omegas that I
needed so now I have allergies to
supplement in my diet
and I feel the best I've ever felt so
I'm like oh really long time maybe over
vegan like what else what else cool
what's the next challenge let's do it I
mean and maybe look the best ever I just
saw this picture of you and your man on
Instagram the ABS are out thank you so
much I'm happy are you okay I'm so happy
someone loves so hot so in love so happy
so wonderful we just celebrated five
months which is like a milestone for me
that's the longest relationship I've
been in like a hot minute he's great and
it's wonderful and everything is just
like easy you know what I love you
staying sober too I mean where are you
at celebrating any milestone markers
with that so I was 2 years sober in June
so at the end of June so we're like 2
years 3 months now and it's just it's so
wonderful to just live my life like and
not have so much like guilt shame
anxiety fear those things I used to like
just completely dictate everything that
I did now it's just like it's again like
just easy and nice so I love when people
like you open up and and talk about
stuff like that because it gives fans
hope and inspiration and you know I know
your sister by the way Ariana's like
real into the health too isn't she like
she's very into like is she plant-based
or where's she falling on so Ariana and
I started being vegan together like five
years ago and like she's somewhere on
this
she's into this fish again things like
that but like it's um it's like you know
like what how you're feeling
energetically like for her but like for
me it's also more of a moral thing so
like I've gone to like I am someone who
like I watched planet Earth and like I
was like yikes I need to like help our
oceans and the best way for me to like
help the ocean was to like stop eating
fish and like stop but I understand like
it's a difficult lifestyle for a lot of
people so what I say is like any meal
helps like even if you just like skip
meat like out one meal a day you're
helping to plan it a little bit you know
step by step you don't have to let go
like ultra cold vegan like overnight
like I get it like I'll meet you halfway
just like don't put the extra meatballs
on your spaghetti one night a week you
know I'll take it